to go straight to nairobi there has been
a result
in the kenyan elections let's join our
africa correspondent yusra al-bagir who
is there uh and can talk to us uh gizra
we're just looking at scenes now tell us
what's happened
william bruto the current deputy
president has just been declared winner
of kenya's presidential race now this
announcement comes after an arduous six
days long day wait of verification of
votes and his opponent and former prime
minister rylo odinga's party have
contested the election and moments
before william obrutto arrived to the
national telling center chairs were
thrown tables were flipped there was a
lot of issues happening and they're now
announcing his win
so we'll see how things go also the
election the electoral commission chair
four out of seven of the electoral
commission commissioners have denounced
the results of this election while their
chairperson has just currently declared
a winner so in the next few hours and
days we will see the true reaction of
people in the country especially as the
results are contested at such a violent
and explosive level israel we saw the
scuffles break out at the center a
little earlier on here on sky news and
you know people of kenya have been
waiting nearly a week for the results
the deputy president william ruto
winning by 50.4
what happens now because you do get a
feeling that this could be contested
i mean before the results were even
announced chair you know uh rylo
dinger's agents stood outside of the
national telling center and contested
the results so what we're likely to see
over the next few hours is is a
contested outcome especially since as i
said commissioners from this very elect
very same electoral commission have come
out and denounced the results of the
election and have doubted the
transparency of the tally
let's see if we can listen to to some of
what's being said now by william router
members of the
independent electoral and boundaries
commission led by
chairman
wafula cebucati
fellow countrymen
and women
good evening
it is
a wonderful evening
and i want to thank god
that
we are here this evening
to witness
this momentous occasion
as
the people of kenya
restate
what is in article one of the
constitution of kenya
that all suffering power
belong to the people of kenya
i want to thank
god for getting us to this point
i want to thank god
that today
we have concluded
this election
[Applause]
i know
that there were predictions
that i won't get
to the ballot
there were predictions
that we won't get here
but because there is a god in heaven
we are here
and i want to in a very special way
say
and confess
that without god
we wouldn't have been here
uh so that is the former deputy
president of kenya william ruto uh now
uh formally uh accepting the results of
the kenyan election making him president
uh winning with 15.49
of the national vote